foreign
he busted into the house through the
front door
and I wrestle with them and
oh
I lost as you can see
but my wife lost more I know who he is
now
but
anyhow we were just one
of all his victims
why do you think he targeted you
I don't know why did it Target a fella
up at the store
why did the target them four people over
there at that little house
Hayden must have chased one of them down
because they found him in the road
but you've escaped you
it's got to go back to Mental Health
that's the problem
guns don't kill people
you know
all these mass shootings upset me now it
really does you know
y'all excuse me
it is such a tragedy we have a good most
people are just really good and we never
would have thought anything like that
would have happened here
I'm so sorry for all that that don't
know
who the victims are but I'm so sorry
the I heard the gunshot from inside my
house I had just woken up and everything
and I look out the window and I see
you know dude walking back here with a
with a shotgun it looks like he was
toting it like this
anyways I I decided to you know put my
shoes on hoodie and everything I already
got my pistol on me so I'll walk outside
and uh people are you know some this
lady honks at me and tells me that to
not go inside so I'm just like cautious
and I walk back and everything kind of
it just observing the situation I go up
to the truck where a guy got shot at and
uh I'm just I check his pulse and
everything make sure he's okay he's he's
already gone at this point
I'm 19 years old concealed carrying like
there needs to be a lot more people like
who who understand that you know dangers
are everywhere and you need to be
protected this guy he didn't he wasn't
protected he's a war veteran man he's
not coming into Arc about this Tiny Town
of ARCA Butler thinking that somebody's
gonna pull a gun on him and his brother
like
man
definitely with seven or six or seven
people you know being confirmed dead uh
it definitely is a relief him being in
custody but uh let's hope for that death
sentence man